I don't think that we can ever have
peace with my family unless the truth is
out there my sources close to the king
say that um he will be extending that
Olive Branch and that he will be
inviting Megan and Harry to the
coronation and it is his son after all
and the King really does want a
Reconciliation in the long
term I've never hacked a phone or told
anybody else to hack a phone and nobody
has produced any actual evidence to
prove that I did 2023 was a pivotal year
for Prince Harry not only did he score a
historic legal victory in his phone
hacking case against the British
[Applause]
tabloids he also attended his father
King Charles's coronation amid a lot of
family
tensioning
King May the king
and released a memoir that made
headlines globally it never needed to be
this way it never needed to get to this
point for the Duke of Sussex the year
began with a truly explosive press tour
as he prepared to release his definitive
tell all
spare in the Memoir Harry offers his
perspective on his fractured
relationship with his family following
his decision to leave the royal family
with his wife Megan Markle in early 2020
in spare Harry addresses the defamatory
stories about Megan published by the
British tablet alleging that his family
played a role in her negative public
portrayal it all went down during a rare
press tour for the book with appearances
on 60 Minutes Britain's ITV ABC News and
The Late Show with Steven coar in my
mind they have written countless books
certainly millions of words have been
dedicated to trying to trash my wife and
myself to the point of where I had to
leave my country having seen my family
and the institution's part in constantly
feeding the British press with lies
mistruths Mis disinformation any way
that I can correct those mistruths is by
writing something the truth in one place
without going through the same people
that they chose to go through I am the
source of that book and the difference
is that instead of hiding behind you
know um unnamed
sources this here are my these these are
my words from from my lips from my mouth
he also criticizes the royal family for
allegedly playing a part in feeding the
media even accusing senior members of
planting stories you know the family
motto is never complain never explain
but it's just a motto and it doesn't
really hold there's a lot of complaining
and a lot of explaining private being
done in through leaks through leaks The
Motto itself is a is a shield to be able
to feed narratives trading of
information personal information on
family members to take one down to build
one up and through unnamed sources uh
where there are no fingerprints Left
Behind they will feed or have a
conversation with the
correspondent and that correspondent
will literally be spoonfed information
and write the story and the bottom of it
they will that they've reached out to
bucking and Palace for comment but the
whole story is Buckingham Palace
commenting Harry claims that his
family's cooperation with the Press was
a major factor in his and Megan's
decision to give up their Royal titles
and step back from the life they once
knew but the conflict wasn't just going
down publicly Harry says even more was
happening behind the scenes he grabbed
me by the collar ripping my necklace and
he knocked me to the floor I landed on
the dog's bowl which cracked under my
back that that's how Harry describes an
alleged confrontation between him and
his older brother Prince William at
Harry's London home in 2019 Harry says
it was all because William allegedly
called Megan difficult rude and abrasive
during an argument that got so heated it
escalated to a physical fight I was
defending my wife and he was coming for
my wife he was shouting at me I was
shouting back at him it wasn't nice it
wasn't pleasant at all and he snapped
and he pushed me to the floor he knocked
you over he knocked me over um I landed
on the dog ball you cut your back yeah I
cut my back I didn't know about it at
the time but um yeah he he apologized
afterwards it was a pretty nasty
experience I can pretty much guarantee
today that if I
wasn't doing therapy sessions like I was
and being able to process that anger and
frustration that I would have fought
back 100% he wanted me to to to hit him
back but I chose not to um but again so
so much of the relationship between me
and William and the way it played out
was because of the people within his
office that were feeding him utter
nonsense you know my brother and I love
each other I love him deeply there has
been a lot of pain between the two of us
especially the last six years um none of
any that I've written and anything I've
included is ever intended to hurt my
family but it squashes this idea that
somehow my wife was the one that
destroyed the relationship between these
two brothers with the palace denying
many of the claims and spare Harry's
Revelations ultimately boil down to a
case of he said they said but just
months after the Memoirs release the
Royal Dynamics played out with the whole
world watching when King Charles made
good on his promise to include Harry in
his
coronation what did you make of Harry's
arrival walking in to Westminster ABY
Harry had always been a loved member of
the royal family so to arrive at this
very celebratory occasion and not be on
speaking terms with so many people
within his own family it made for a very
uncomfortable arrival Harry played the
role of the Prodigal Son sitting three
row back as William knelt before their
father I William Prince of Wales pledge
my loyalty to you and faith and truth I
will bear on to
you it was the ABS abolute image of an
outsider of someone who is not a part of
his family who has been cussed drift and
personally I I think it was very very
sad and while no words appeared to be
exchanged between the brothers Harry's
face kind of said it all did he and
William make any eye contact at all I
couldn't see any sign of eye contact
whatsoever with Harry we see sadness so
we see the eyebrows come together we see
the the mouth droop so he was
experienced a combination of kind of
frustration anxiety u a little bit of
sadness May the King live forever there
is still a very real rift at the heart
of the House of Windsor Harry kept the
family reunion brief hurrying off almost
immediately after the ceremony to make
it back to California for his son
Archie's fourth birthday and this visit
was a blink and you miss it visit I mean
he was here for just over 24 hours he
got in late on the Friday and by the
time that the royal family were having
the official pictures taken here at
Buckingham Palace Harry was already on
route to the airport and I think many
people including some members of his own
family wondered why he bothered coming
at all do you think Archie's birthday
was used as an excuse I think Archie's
birthday was very convenient with 2023
coming to an end the Royal RI seemingly
remains in place but Harry is finishing
the year off strong with a victory in
his historic phone hacking trial it's my
duty to uncover this exploitation and
bribery that happens within our media on
December 15th a UK Court ruled in favor
of the Duke of Sussex confirming that
Harry was indeed targeted by mirror
group newspapers which includes the
Daily Mirror formerly run by Pierce
Morgan who maintains his innocence I've
never hacked a phone or told anybody
else to hack a phone I wasn't called as
a witness nor was I asked to provide any
statement so I wasn't able to respond to
the many false allegations that were
spewed about me in court by all foes of
mine with an axe to grind Harry was
awarded about
$18,000 in Damages and in a statement to
ET Harry called the ruling vindicating
after the win Harry and Megan wished
everyone a happy holiday season with
this card featuring the couple at the
Invictus games all smiles writing thanks
for all the support in 2023 I will focus
on my my life my amazing family that I'm
so grateful to have my two kids who are
bouncing up and down me this morning I'm
happy my family's happy it's been really
hard at times but I guess there's also a
lot of people who refuse to accept that
I could be happy out here because of
what I've left behind but the reality is
I've never been
happier